The political ad campaign produced by a left
wing pack called American bridge and the concept
of this ad campaign, they've got a number
of ads is Trumpists who would admit it was
a mistake to vote for Donald Trump.
Now I've said before as a strategy for winning
2020 for individual activists like we are,
I don't believe arguing with is to get them
to vote for somebody else is a good strategy
for the left because number one 62% of Trump
has said they would never question their support
for Donald Trump or reconsider it.
No matter what Trump does, even hypothetically,
so at, at, at the get go with two thirds of
Trump, you're simply wasting your breath.
But also it takes a lot to convince someone
to change their mind, particularly when they're
experiencing the degree of cognitive dissonance
that so many Trump supporters are.
So a better strategy for us at the individual
level is let's get people registered.
Let's get out the vote from people who already
don't like Trump, but to the extent that may
be disaffected, disaffected Trumpists in the
38% who are not committed no matter what to
Donald Trump, to the extent that they might
have minds changed.
I actually think that this is a pretty clever
ad campaign for a few reasons, which I'll
tell you about in a moment.
Let's check out the, uh, one of these ads.
First
[inaudible]
my name is Mark Graham and I lived in the
area all my life.
[inaudible]
basically it's a blue collar town, start off
large manufacturing base lot, a lot of water
shipping, rum running back in the days.
[inaudible].
I voted for Donald Trump in 2016 because I
thought he would make a change.
Did he make a change?
Not for the good.
Donald Trump only plays favorites for people
like himself.
Not URI, Pennsylvania.
The president's of bullying because it's his
way or no way.
He doesn't understand life around here.
He thinks he's the smartest person ever.
I don't think people believe that.
I don't believe Donald Trump is on the side
of the American people.
I think he's on his own side.
If I could go back in time, I would tell myself
to be aware of the changes that president
Trump has made voting for Donald Trump in
2020 it would be like putting gasoline on
a fire.
AB pack is responsible.
The content of this ad, so of course the fact
that ads like these exist is terrible in the
sense that our system is broken.
We need money out of politics.
I hate packs.
I hate all of this ancillary spending.
I mean these, these are well-produced ads.
This is not cheap.
The air time is not cheap.
I've said it a million times, but to the extent
that for the 2020 election, this is the game.
This is the game of politics in the United
States.
This is actually a pretty clever, there are
a lot of Trumpists who won't vote for someone
else because they don't want to admit to themselves
that they made a mistake.
They don't want to have to face others with
the fact that they might abandon Donald Trump
because they're worried about what the reaction
might be.
Ads like these with disaffected Trumpists
who say publicly, I'm not voting Trump again,
this conserve effectively like a sort of permission
being granted to Trumpists to abandoned Donald
Trump because as group think might call it,
that is effectively what many of these Trumpists
are waiting for.
I am sort of questioning my vote, but unless
I get permission from the group to go somewhere
else in 2020, uh, electorally, I'm not going
to do it.
And when the margin of victory for Trump ended
up being about 77, 78,000 votes in three key
States, including Pennsylvania, uh, where
that voter, um, uh, featured in the ad is
from a few ads like these well produced and
broadcast in those key States could actually
be the difference maker.
This is a very interesting campaign and it's
also smart because it's focusing on rural
working class voters.
That's a group that in a sense propelled Donald
Trump to victory in 2016 in which at least
stereotypically Democrats don't do as well
with in many elections.
This isn't so much going after Trump over
specific issues.
It's a general economic, but it's not going
after Trump for something specific that he
said it's not related to a Ukraine or impeachment.
Uh, and that has been a criticism.
Some people wrote to me saying, these ads
are too vague.
I actually think that that's good.
This is a former Trumpist who hopefully is
relatable when he says, I made a mistake.
I'm not voting for Trump.
And you don't have to vote for Trump either.
Let's look at one other one.
This is David Sobero.
It's from Eau Claire, Wisconsin.
My name is David silver road rich and they
also call me Sobel.
I live just South of Oclair, Wisconsin.
I love the community.
I love the scenery.
The one thing I really like to do most is
to go out to the snowmobile water, cross channel,
national championship.
They race snowmobiles across water.
It is amazing.
They just go fast enough where they don't
sing, but sometimes they do and that's fun.
Today I work for a plumbing and heating company
in 2016 I backed Trump because he wasn't a
politician and that to me made him look kind
of like me or a lot of other people that want
things done in the country, but it seemed
like now that he's in office, he's right in
there with them being all crazy.
He definitely thinks he's above the law.
Maybe that's because he's a businessman.
If I could go back three years, I would say
just think it over a little bit harder.
In 2016 I voted for president Trump, but not
this time.
AB pack is responsible for the content of
this ad.
These are the types of ads that could really
pull people who are unsure the diehards, it
won't matter, but you don't need to convince
the diehards.
It was just 75,003 States.
Take the stigma out of changing your mind.
Changing your mind can be portrayed and politics
is flip-flopping negatively or it can be doing
the adult thing.
Owning your mistakes.
When you have more information, you come to
a different conclusion and doing the right
thing.
This time around is the way that I would frame
it and of course, you know the die hard.
Trump is, we'll say the people featured in
these ads are fake former Trumpists.
They were never for Trump.
All of that stuff doesn't matter because 62%
of the trumpets are never going to reconsider
their support of Donald Trump.
This is meant to appeal to the 38% of Trumpists
who are gettable.
They're not in the, I'm with them no matter
what camp and it could make a difference in
2020 I think that this is a good ad, a good
ad campaign.
Let me know what you think.
I will remind you we are getting closer to
Thanksgiving 2019 we are going to be on maybe
Thanksgiving day, maybe black Friday.
I'm not sure yet.
We are going to be doing our last major membership
drive promo of the year.
If you want to sign up for a membership at
an obscenely discounted rate, I mean it's,
it's, it's so low, low, low, low priced that
I can't even say it because, uh, I don't even
know why.
I just can't.
That's the story I'm telling you today.
Anyway, if you want to be notified about just
like the best membership deal of the year
on either Thanksgiving day or the day after,
get on our newsletter@davidpakman.com it takes
a second to sign up.
You will be notified on whichever day we decide
to send it out Thanksgiving, maybe the day
after of this obscene membership special and
I will gladly welcome your support at that
hugely discounted rate.
Get on our newsletter@davidpakman.com make
sure to follow me on Twitter at D Pacman.
We will take a quick break
and come back with much more right after this